- Look at our three
Texas girls hangin' out.
I like this.
- Don't you love it?
- I really do, we're taking
over New York. (laughing)
- We're taking over New York.
- We are.
- And we just ran into each other.
I don't know if you remember,
I was at Chelsea Handler's stand-up.
- Oh yeah.
- Yes.
- That was really fun.
- Yeah, it was back backstage.
I know, I was like, totally
not hair and makeup.
I don't look like this outside. (laughing)
(audience laughing)
And I was like, "I don't
know if she knows who I am,"
but I was like, "Hi, what's up?"
But anyway, I saw you, you had
a whole crew there as well.
It was so fun.
- It was really fun.
- How hilarious is Chelsea Handler?
- Oh my God, everyone,
Sam Jay that opened,
like it was like such a fun night.
And it just reminded me
like it's one of the
reasons why I moved here,
I want a life.
- (laughing) Yeah.
- And you have a life!
- But comedy is so important.
I do, but comedy is so important,
and it makes you feel so good.
- Yes.
- Yeah,
it was hilarious and so fun.
And she's the best big sister
that's not blood related
to us that we've every had.
- We call her sissy.
- I know, y'all do.
I know, I knew that about that.
But Halloween just happened,
so what did y'all do?
Did you go trick-or-treating?
This is my first Halloween here.
- Did you have fun?
- It... Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- It's a lot, it's a lot, it's a lot.
- It was different.
I think my kids are too polite
for this city right now.
They need to-
- [Jenna Bush Hager] Yeah, they gotta...
Well, my son-
- [Barbra Bush] That's good though.
- That shows you how much
he loves New York City,
was a New York City rat firefighter.
(audience laughing)
- That's very specific.
- It was a New York City rat firefighter-
(audience applauding)
And then, I was fire.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh my God, I love that.
- [Jenna Bush Hager] And a pizza.
- I love that.
- You were a fire pizza.
- I was a fire pizza.
- Oh, one of my daughters was an angel.
Or my... I only have one daughter.
- Yeah. (laughing)
- My daughter was an angel.
One of my kids is what
I meant, was an angel.
- I know, they are angels, right?
- It was very fun.
I think my daughter though,
got a little overwhelmed.
There was thousands of people.
- It's overwhelming.
- It's a lot.
- Like I've never done it here,
and I was like, "Interesting," yeah.
And I had to kinda fight
for my kids to get up there to get candy.
- No, I know, I know.
- It was insane.
(Barbra laughing)
- It's a lot.
- Two years old, right?
- She's two, she was a kitty.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Aw.
- Meow was her first word.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Aw, so she likes cats.
- So she just dressed
as herself, basically.
- Okay, she just likes cats.
- And Barbra was a star cat.
- What does that mean?
- It's just a cat with a lot of glitter.
- Oh, okay.
You're a fancy cat, I like it.
- [Barbra Bush] Oh, there we
are in a blow-up inflatable-
- [Kelly Clarkson] I love
that too 'cause why not?
(Kelly laughing)
- Yeah, well and by the way,
we were in that inflatable,
which is like a hamster ball-
- [Kelly Clarkson] I've done that before.
- And we can't move-
- We got stuck.
- Because we're large.
- I can't do it 'cause I get
sick, I get motion sickness.
- It was hot.
- It's harder than you think it is.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- And then two little boys zoomed into us,
and they were like, "Y'all are slow."
(audience laughing)
I know.
- So two, that's a fun age sometimes.
Terrible twos yet, or?
- Not yet, she's ador...
Well-
- You might not... I
didn't get terrible twos,
I got threenager.
- Well, that's what I'm scared
is that it's just delayed.
And I keep saying she's perfect,
and then she's gonna sneak up on me.
She's super joyful.
Meow was her first word,
but her other word is no,
she's a totally unreliable narrator.
- Just no.
- So I'll say like...
She'll be eating watermelon,
and I'll say, "Oh, is that watermelon?"
"No."
- She's already gaslighting her,
she's already gaslighting her.
Kids are the biggest gaslighters.
- A young age.
- She does it with the cutest voice-
- Yeah, that's gaslighting.
- That I bought it.
So now, 15 years from now,
she's been encouraged to
act like this by her mother.
- Oh my gosh.
I love... I miss...
I don't miss, I love every age.
But mine are seven and nine at this point,
and it's like you just...
I was out trick-or-treating with them
and seein' all these little
kids in these little costumes.
Aw.
- It's very cozy.
- It's very dangerous.
(everyone laughing)
'Cause I did not need
more children. (laughing)
I'm already a single mom.
So your boy, you have one
boy and two girls, right?
- Yes.
- Okay, so I have a boy and a girl,
that's very different.
- Yeah, oh my gosh.
- Are you experiencing that?
- When Hal entered the equation,
it was like we didn't
even know what to do.
It was like all this boy energy
that our house kinda needed, you know?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause it was a lotta
girl things, vibes.
- But boys are like Tasmanian devils.
- [Jenna Bush Hager] Oh yeah.
- Yeah.
- No, he leads with his head.
- I mean, he was also a New
York City rat for Halloween.
- Which is kind of awesome.
- [Jenna Bush Hager] Which is awesome.
- The foreshadowing of that,
of who he's gonna be is pretty magical.
(everyone laughing)
It's like alright, I love that.
- He's not afraid to be himself, for sure.
- Yeah, mine loves scary,
and I think that's
insane 'cause he's seven.
But he was like, "Mom, take a picture."
Everything just horribly scary,
he was like, "Take a picture, take video,"
I was like, "Why?"
- So we can look back over it?
- To watch this?
Yeah, but he loves it.
So wait, I wanna show this
photo 'cause this is adorable.
Do you remember this photo?
- [Jenna And Barbra] Wow.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Look at you.
I remember those dresses.
- [Jenna Bush Hager] Wow.
- With the lace on the...
I have literally a church
picture I took with my mom,
and I'm wearing like
something almost identical.
- Those drop waist things were popular.
- It was a drop waist.
- Which is not good for
girls with curves later on.
- We were chubby.
- [Kelly Clarkson] You were not.
- Well, we were.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Uh, what?
- Not there.
- Not there, but I was.
- I'm like,
"I don't think you know
what chubby is." (laughing)
- Was I chubby?
- No.
- Barbara, I was-
- You can't ask someone that,
she's not gonna be like,
"You were a chub club."
Like, she's not gonna-
- Barbara, was I a-
- Look at her there,
you're not chubby there.
- No, not there, but in
my life was I chubby?
- Well, there was a stage.
- Thank you.
- But it was-
(audience laughing)
- I had a stage.
- Thank you.
- I've had many stages
actually. (laughing)
- Yeah, it was college, it wasn't then.
- Yeah.
Were you always dressed alike?
Like did they-
- My mom liked that-
- Often, yeah.
- Often, okay.
- And we rebelled.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- And it was fun to rebel,
you know what I mean?
- And then, we took each
other's clothes instead.
- Yeah, exactly.
Although now, I can't fit
into her clothes, and so...
- Ugh, I don't fit into mine.
I love losing weight-
- Are you joking me?
You look amazing!
- No, no, no, wait.
I love losing weight,
but here's the thing-
(audience cheering)
But, jeans are so hard.
I feel like jeans are so hard
when you have a butt
and like smaller waist.
- Do you want to take you jean shopping?
- I don't want to go shopping.
- Shall I just do what I do for Hoda
and send you some jeans?
- Oh my God, do you do...
I'm Hoda? (laughing)
- I shop for Hoda constantly.
- I'm the worst.
Jeans are so hard.
Anyway-
- We'll figure it out.
- This is a first world
problem, I realize,
and it's a great problem.
But I showed up today and I was like,
"Look, I didn't have
anything else to wear,"
and they're like, "Why are
you wearing those?" (laughing)
- That's cute.
- No, no, my jeans I wore here.
- 'Cause they didn't fit you.
- They're bigger, yeah.
- Yeah.
- But I was going for
that really cool TLC vibe,
like the baggy vibe.
- Totally,
"Don't Go Chasing Waterfall's," mm-hmm.
- Exactly, I love we're all the same age.
Their new book is called "Love
Comes First," it's out now.
So you've had a couple
books, right, together?
So why this book, why "Love Comes First"?
- Okay, well we wrote about sisters.
- Being sisters was sort
of always our inspiration
'cause we were born with a partner.
There's nothing better than having a twin.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- So all of our first
books were about sisters,
and then our family
started looking different
than what we had grown up with.
She had a boy-
- Yeah.
And she had a baby.
- And I had a nugget.
- A nugget-
- And so then we wanted
to write another book
that wasn't solely centered on sisters,
but more about how there's
plenty of room for love.
You can have your blood relatives,
you can have your chosen family.
And love is infinite and
there's always room for more,
and that's what we wanted
to encourage with our kids.
- We feel like there's room
for love in this world.
And if you look at the-
- A need.
- There's a need.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- And if you see the way our kids act,
they're just full of it, you know?
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- They know that love
is infinite and it's-
- Adults jade them.
- 100%.
- That's the thing.
We ruin it, yeah.
- 100%.
So, this is for all of them
that are sort of showing us the way.
- I love that 'cause
blended is so important too.
And also like,
I didn't grow up around
my brother and sister,
but like I had friends that became family.
- Totally, yeah, you choose your family-
- That counts as well.
- And that matters too.
- Yeah.
So you're doing a book tour, right?
- Yes.
- We're going to Texas, girl.
- Are you?
- Oh yeah.
- Later today.
- Are you gonna get queso?
- Oh yeah we are, today.
- Everyday.
- We're gonna get queso.
- I'm so jealous, whatever
- Remember when I
brought you that big vat?
- Remember that vat of queso?
- [Jenna Bush Hager] That
could have lasted over a-
- You're my favorite guest,
I know, I know, for like families, I know.
So wait, are y'all good
at traveling together?
Me and my sister are awesome
at traveling together.
- We're great at traveling
together. (laughing)
- We love it.
We actually get there and they're like,
"Okay Mrs. Hager, here's your room.
Mrs. Bush, here's yours."
And we're like, "Oh, no, no,
we'll forego the two rooms
for the fantasy suite," you know?
Like, we're like-
(audience laughing)
- Yeah.
No, my sister and I are similar too.
When we go on vacations,
there's always so many of us too,
that we end up like packing...
Like going together.
My sister and I, or Tricia and I,
end up going together all the time.
But yeah, we always
share a room, it's fun!
- Yeah, we share a room.
- Because you're not
really in the room a ton,
you're working, or you're
visiting whatever city you're in.
- And it's fun to be with each other.
It gives us a slumber party
that we don't get to have.
- It's the road trip that
we've been desperate for.
- Exactly.
- [Kelly Clarkson] I love a road trip.
- We do too.
- Yeah.
Okay, so what are some
of your favorite cities,
your favorite moments,
that you've been to?
- Well, we like going to Texas.
- Yes.
- We'll go to Texas this weekend
and be with our mom for her birthday.
- [Kelly Clarkson] That's exciting.
- And we're really excited
that there was a Texas
Rangers win, so we'll-
- Yes.
- Did you celebrate?
- I didn't celebrate.
(audience cheering)
I've been like...
My household has been weird
with fighting sickness,
so I didn't celebrate, I wasn't watching,
I was just being a single
mom taking care of kids.
- Well I know, it feels
like people didn't watch,
but we watched.
- We did, we were in.
- Yeah, I didn't get to
watch, I was so bummed,
but we have this whole text
group of sports ball people and-
- Sports balls.
- Well, it's our fantasy league.
- I'm into fantasy football now.
- Yeah, I know.
- Yes, hardcore.
- I heard you were.
- What's your team name?
- I just lost my quarterback...
Oh, the Red Flag Collectors. (laughing)
You know, 'cause they throw
yellow flags, (laughing)
and I collect red ones.
Anyway, I had to get a
new quarterback, whatever.
I'm super proud of the Rangers.
- [Jenna Bush Hager] I
know, isn't that awesome?
- This is very cool.
Yeah, that's how I found out was via text.
But I have to say, Schwarzenegger
was just here, Arnold,
and he said the craziest
story that I did not know.
He broke your grandma's ankle, was it?
- Yeah, in the 90's.
- Yeah.
- And she wasn't super
young, so that would've hurt.
- [Jenna And Barbra] No.
- Yeah.
- He went sledding with our grandfather-
- No, grandmother.
- No, he ran into Ganny on the sled.
- By the way, that whole...
Like, they went sledding?
Like can you imagine like
two 75-year-olds being like,
"Hey Arnold, let's sled!"
(audience laughing)
- I kinda love it, I kind of
love your family just for that.
That's kind of amazing.
- I just can't get my head
really wrapped around that.
- He said she took it like a champ though.
I would expect nothing less.
- She would, she would.
- She definitely did.
- Yeah, strong woman, yeah.
- I think she liked having
stories to tell too,
and that's a good one.
- And not many people can say that.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's pretty crazy.
I probably woulda made something up too,
"He got very angry at dinner, and he"...
No, I'm just kidding.
- Yeah, totally, totally.
- So you shared name with that grandma,
like so was that ever hard growing up?
- It was awkward.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- 'Cause she was the president's wife.
- [Barbra Bush] She was the first lady,
- [Kelly Clarkson] I do remember that.
- When she was in second grade.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- So like I would call Dominoes and order,
thinking I was really
responsible and order a pizza,
and they would hang up on me,
think that I was prank calling.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yes.
- 'Cause that was really
the prank calling era.
- I was like, "Did you prank call?"
I totally outta prank called.
- We totally pranked called,
we loved prank calling,
loved it.
- I wanna prank call soon.